greetings this is rob sanders from
simply learn and today we're going to
talk about seo
tips and tricks so let's get started and
throughout this series we're going to
have a few tips to share with you and
we'll start out with tip number one
opt for smarter ways to do keyword
research
and so if you listen to any of our seo
tutorials in the past you know that
keyword research
is the first step but the most crucial
step
in starting seo so when we do keyword
research
we want to be able to basically find
keywords that we
feel are relevant to our business that
we want to be found
on search for and so here are a few tips
that can help you do that research
in a more efficient manner the first
thing we want to do
is identify a list of keywords that are
relevant so we only
want to focus on relevant keywords for
our business
that's a given so what i would suggest
is as a best practice maybe you know put
down some of those keywords in a
spreadsheet
so think of them as a theme of keywords
because when you do
research you're going to want to include
a theme of keywords related to one
another so you can pick the best ones
out of that theme and so as an example
if we have a company that sells dry figs
in a spreadsheet as an example if i show
you a spreadsheet maybe
we want to focus in on just dried fig
and maybe we want to focus on dried fig
recipes so go ahead and put those in a
column
you know some of these keywords that you
know you want to be found for
so that's really the first step they
need to be relevant so put them in a
spreadsheet
so that you can build keywords around
that list then we want to choose
keywords and
when we choose keywords we want to have
some criteria
around choosing them and so we always
want to choose keywords with a lot of
volume
and what i mean by volume i mean how
many people
on average type in that keyword or a
related keyword per month the second
criteria
is the keyword a product fit meaning you
know is the keyword relevant you always
want to stay
true to relevancy the third is
commercial intent
what is the intent of the keyword
is it trying to get us a sale is it
answering a question
so what is the intent of that keyword
and then last its difficulty so we want
to definitely take a look at how
difficult
a keyword is to rank for on organic
search
so that's some of the criteria you may
have some additional criteria that you
want to use but
this is the criteria basically for
choosing keywords
so again we want to prefer keywords with
high volume
you want to be careful of seasonality so
remember seasonality
in this example christmas tree you're
only going to have a spike
you know during the winter or excuse me
the october november december months
so be careful of seasonality when
choosing high volume keywords
and again keywords that are relevant to
your product even though it doesn't have
much search volume
relevancy always trump's uh volume or
any other metric
commercial intent so we want to look at
keywords that
for example have buy in them they may
have low search volume
but if somebody's typing in that keyword
then we
can insinuate that the consumer who
typed in that keyword is ready to make
the purchase
so we want to look at what the intent is
of that keyword
and then again the difficulty always opt
for keywords that have low
difficulty or competition and so in
order to get these metrics
we can use third-party tools i'm going
to show you a couple of examples of
third-party tools
you can use that will give you some of
this information
so the first tool i'm going to show you
is google ads
keyword planner so if i'm having google
ads account
i could simply go to tools and then
choose the keyword planner
and from there i want to find new
keywords so if i choose the keyword
dried figs because that's the key word i
put in my
spreadsheet that i'm interested in
optimizing for
and then maybe drive fake recipes that
was the other
keyword theme so if i enter those two
keywords in
just to begin with basically what google
is going to give me
is the average search monthly volume
so here i can see dried figs i have an
average monthly search volume
8 100. that means on average over the
last 12 months
that's how many people have typed in
that keyword here i can see a little bit
of a trend
i just hover my mouse over that graph i
could see
again for seasonality impact if there is
any seasonality what the volume is on
average per month
then i can see the competition is high
and because this is google ads because
it's paid search
they're going to give me a sense or an
idea of what i should be bidding on that
keyword
now that's another topic for another day
but it's good information to have
because if you're not ranking for a
keyword
you could decide to bid on it for paid
search so
don't discard the bidding information
go ahead and put it in a spreadsheet for
later use but for now we're focused in
on
keywords that are relevant how much
volume how much competition okay
so once i get this information here i
can simply go back to my spreadsheet
and put that information in there what's
the volume for dried fig
what is the competition now for
competition
notice that google ads gives us a higher
low
now if we're trying to measure ratio
between
volume and competition we want to get an
actual sense of what that competition is
so
what i always do as a best practice is
go into google search
if i go to google search and i type in
dried figs
i'm gonna see the actual volume is 34
million five hundred thousand
so i could see that's the actual search
volume for this particular keyword
however if i add a syntax called
all in title before that keyword with a
colon
space and then hit enter then i could
see
the actual volume reduces to 31 000
and basically what this tells me is that
31
000 listings or results have the keyword
dried figs in the title tag
so if a web page has dried fig
our targeted keyword in the title tag
then ideally we can insinuate
that that page is trying to rank for
that keyword so therefore in order for
us
to rank number one on google we have to
jump over 31 000
results so we want to be able to include
this information
into our keyword analysis so if i go
into our keyword analysis here
and i go ahead and enter in that
information so what's my keyword my
keyword is dried figs
okay my volume was 80 my competition was
31
000. and so that gives me a ratio of
81 divided by 31 000
if i make that into a percentage
basically 26
so that's my keyword effectiveness index
or kei
or ratio between volume and competition
and so that's an a way that you can
gather information is by using google
ads enter the information into
a spreadsheet and then sort all your
data by kei
you could sort it by volume you could
sort it by competition
all these metrics matter alternatively
as another tool you can use moz
so moz has a keyword explorer tool
okay so if i type in the keyword dried
figs
focusing on the united states i could
see that moz says hey look there's
anywhere between 4 300 and 6 500
in terms of volume out of 100 the is 41.
and so i can expect a click-through rate
of you know 41 and so
basically the great thing about moz's
keyword explorer tool
is i can also look at the serp analysis
search engine results
pages what serp stands for and i can
analyze the serp
for a particular keyword in moz so i
want to be able to understand what my
competition is doing
so here i can see if i really want to
try and optimize for that keyword
i could see what the other pages are
ranked for that keyword
in the on page one i can also see what
local results show up for that keyword
so here i can see that we have a number
of different
sites listed here so if we want to be
number one these are the sites that are
basically above us that we need to climb
over to be number one on google
so i find that the keyword explore tool
in moz is very helpful for understanding
your competition as well as getting a
alternative check on volume and
competition
or difficulty if you will and so
remember we want to identify a list of
keywords that are relevant i can't
stress that enough
we want to choose keywords based on
difficulty
we want to choose keywords based on
volume on commercial intent
and more important relevancy we can also
identify trends from a site search query
like amazon
and know what your competitors are
ranking for so
we can also go back into moz and we can
see
just by typing in some of the keywords
we're focusing on we can see if our
competitors are ranking
for the same keywords just by using that
keyword explorer tool
and then another thing we want to look
at is lsi
or latent semantic indexing so that's a
fancy word
which basically means we want to find
keywords related to the topic of
the page you're trying to optimize so if
there are other keywords on that page
then you could sway in that direction
and so when it comes to choosing
keywords you want to choose always a
primary and secondary keyword
and so if we go back to our spreadsheet
it doesn't necessarily always have to be
just one keyword
it doesn't necessarily have to be dried
figs we could choose another keyword
that has a good volume to competition
ratio
so we want to choose keywords that are
always relevant
and if we're analyzing nothing but
relevant keywords then we want to be
able to choose keywords
that have a good ratio between volume
and competition so you always want to
choose at least two keywords
per page we could also stay up to date
on industry news
as we'll help you learn new jargon so it
doesn't hurt to
subscribe to sites like search engine
watch or search engine land
they have lots of good tips so here i'll
show you what that one of those
sites look like if i simply just go to
search engine watch
dot com i find this is a good resource
to stay up on the latest news when it
comes to search engines
here we could see why seo and front-end
developers are the perfect search
marketing team
another article about optimizing your
channel youtube channel five easy steps
so there's a lot of information here on
search engine watch
that pertain to seo and keyword research
we could also look at other third-party
sites like
wikipedia reddit and core for example so
if i go to
quora i can do a search for dried figs
and i could see
what's being written about that topic so
that should give me some ideas
to build a keyword a list around so for
example the health benefits of dried
figs
okay are dry figs safe for diabetes best
ways to eat dry figs so those are all
good keyword themes that we could build
a keyword list around and i did that
simply just by typing in dried figs on
core
so that's a a good tip for you to
leverage
when you're trying to build out a
keyword list okay let's
uh talk about tip number two which is
publish high quality
content to get more traffic to your
website
so it's all about content so we've
already done the keyword research
we still need to kind of merge the two
when we talk about merging the two it's
not just building content around those
keywords it's much more than that when
it comes to seo
and so that's why we always talk about
high quality content
so let's talk about some of the tips
that can help you create
high quality content so first tip
is we want to be able to publish longer
and engaging content
longer and engaging content tends to
rank higher in google why
because you have more content to work
with and when you have more content to
work with
you can optimize it you can structure it
you can insert different assets like
videos and images
and by keeping it long you're going to
likely
keep it engaging and so google tends to
lean
in favor of content that is well
organized structured
and long because it is more likely to be
engaging for the end user
we definitely want to include those
target keywords
so you want to be able to you know
insert those keywords
into those meta tag descriptions into
those title tags into those alt tags but
you want to work them in naturally
you don't want to force anything content
should be naturally written
because if it's naturally written it's
going to be engaging so we want to use
lsi keywords in the content so
lsi or basically latent semantic
indexing
basically just means different terms and
concepts
related to your target keywords so feel
free to use
terms that are similar to what you're
currently using
these keywords can definitely be used
for seo because they create
more visibility and potentially higher
rankings because it gives you an
opportunity to use keywords that are
natural
and work for different variations and
let's look at examples so if you're
optimizing an e-commerce category page
and your keyword is one mix used for men
so we want to use keywords closely
related to
one mix used for men for example running
shoes for men or sport running shoes for
men
outdoor sport shoes or air cushion shoes
let's take a look an example of amazon
so if i go to amazon
i could see the one mix shoes for men
page
and if i look at this page i could see a
lot of product and each product
has basically some content associated
with it
i.e the title of the particular product
and so you want to be able to use
different descriptors
for this particular product for example
men's running shoes
or breathable lightweight gym sports
shoes
or lightweight casual sneakers or
walking casual sneaker
all of these are lsi related keywords
they're
similar to what we're trying to optimize
for so you don't necessarily always have
to
be brand heavy or stick with one keyword
you could definitely show variation
especially on the e-commerce side if
you're dealing with different products
so we want to make the content readable
with the help of visuals
subtitles and bullet points so if you're
e-commerce
you want to make sure that page is laid
out properly
easy to read you hear i could see the
descriptor along with the title all kind
of merge together
and so there's no breakout of okay this
is the product name
this description it's kind of one
all-in-one which i like
it just makes it more natural sounding
okay and you can see these are all
broken out
uh pretty well laid out page and amazon
is more or less
you know consistent in terms of how
their pages are laid out
so make it readable add visuals add
subtitles add bullet points
it helps break out a lot of the content
especially if you have a long amount of
content or large amount of content so
the use of subtitles bullet points and
visuals will help break it out
structure it and make it more engaging
for the end user
you definitely want to write an
effective and organized content in order
to reduce the bounce rate so
there is correlation between engagement
and bounce rate the more you structure
the more you add visuals the more you
add subtitles the more engaged
somebody's gonna be the less
likely they are to bounce from the pitch
we also want to
share customer reviews and ratings so
if you have a web page you sell products
even if you don't sell products
it's always good to have testimonials or
some type of customer review
so if we go back to our example on
amazon
and we clicked on a product uh one of
the running shoe products
we look here we can see the image we
could see
kind of the description well i may not
be so
interested in buying this product i want
to know a little bit more about it
well that's where the breaking point
comes in that's where the decision
factor comes in where
if i read other reviews then i can
possibly
have my mind made up to buy this product
so here i could see
that not only there were reviews but
there's testimonials so i could see that
here you can see that there's a lot of
stars
and you can see the kind of the review
title these running shoes are very
comfortable and lightweight
so you have a lot of different feedback
and so reading custom reviews is always
helpful because
even though you're making the decision
it kind of will help sway you in one
direction or another at least it does
for me so that's the
the beauty of a customer review and a
rating we want to be able to use those
to our advantage
and then you want to be able to update
your content on a regular basis so
and that goes for testimonials and
reviews you want to make sure you're
always getting reviews
if you're always getting reviews then
that's just adding to the particular
product and so if you're always updating
your content on a regular basis as well
then google's going to be able to see
that and google likes fresh content okay
we also want to include
the benefits of the product so if you're
selling a product any product you always
want to include the benefits you want to
do as much as you can
to make your product engage into the end
user enticing so that they can buy it
so in addition to customer reviews or
adding content about the product you
want to include benefits so
if we go back to amazon here we can see
amazon lists a lot of the benefits or
one mix in this case
list a lot of the benefits so here you
can see
all the descriptors about the particular
product it's got
rubber sole it's got a breathable
textile lining
you get free high quality socks with
every shoe so
these are some of the features and if we
continue to scroll down
we could see some of the details about
the fabric type
specifics about the fabric and a lot of
information on this product page
even a sizing chart so a lot of
different features
that will help the end user make the
decision so
don't hold back add as much information
as you possibly can as much information
as you have
available it doesn't hurt because in the
end what you're trying to do from a
product perspective is sell the product
and
you can't really sell it unless you have
information that's going to convince the
user
that this product is what they want to
buy so include the warranty
size recommendation return policy and
some offers
so it should all be listed on the page
easy for the end user to see
so can't stress it enough provide as
much
product information as possible go back
here here it has a sizing chart
what colors are available again some of
the descriptors
if i scroll down here i can see some
more
of the benefits you know waffle rubber
outsole soft deodorant insole again
fabric type it's got all sorts of
information
it's got images about the fabric itself
the shoe itself how it's structured so a
lot of information about this and it
even does a comparison
and so there's a lot of information
about this particular product
so don't hold back add as much as you
can to convince the end user
so in the case of the one mix on amazon
you know they had a sizing chart
you know they had an faq being
additional information
what other products that customers view
from one mix and then testimonials so
these are some of the basic bits of
information you want to add on your page
if you don't have customer reviews it's
okay add faq in its place again the end
result is to convince the customer to
purchase the product
and then build a comprehensive internal
linking structure of web pages
so every product page should link to
similar products
so if i go back here here i can see
other products
from one mix so you should always have a
linking structure
so that if the end user doesn't want to
particularly buy that particular product
then you have links available so they
can go to another page
and then add different varieties and
related short videos of the product
so if we go back to our product page you
know they have different varieties that
they're showcasing here
they have the size chart they even have
a
size convertible chart so if you're
dealing with metrics
you can go over to us metrics feet vice
versa you can add a video
you know show a video of if you're
selling running shoes throw a video
somebody working out
you know it doesn't have to be a
full-blown commercial per se
but it could be a short 30-second video
of what the shoe looks like
on somebody else's feet so that they
could see somebody walking with those
shoes on
so video doesn't have to be a big
production you can do it right from your
phone
so review your content before you
publish this goes without saying
you want to do that just you make sure
you include everything
possible because when the content does
get published remember google
is going to index that content when they
index it it's going to show up in the
search results so we want to make sure
we have
all the information readily available
not only for the end user but for google
as well
we want to be able to analyze our meta
tags in url to improve click-through
rate so this is important because
the meta tags i.e the title tag in the
meta description
and the urls what shows up in google
search results so
we have title tags step first that's the
first important element that's what
shows up
in the search results so what we want to
do is we want to optimize the title tag
and when we optimize it we want to use
modifiers and when i say modifiers i
mean
you know feel free to use the word best
or cash back
or free shipping or discount so for
example if you're selling running shoes
25 best sneakers or up to 70
off or free shipping or buy shoes on
discount very action oriented
but you know it includes these modifiers
that are going to help
somebody click on that link so
some tips for optimizing the title tag
in addition to modifiers we want to
watch the title length
and we want to include those target
keywords in the title tag so
remember you're likely going to have two
keywords to work with
you want to have at least one of those
keywords in your title tag
so with the modifier you know up to 60
to 65 characters in length with that
targeted keyword
should get you a good title tag that's
going to get somebody to click on it so
let's look at an example
so if i type in the keyword best recipes
for dried figs
you know here i could scroll down here's
my title tag stands out
my url is right underneath that and
underneath the url
are is the meta description and so here
i can see some modifiers
188 best autumn dried fake recipes
or 25 fantastic fig recipes or 10
best cooking dried fig recipes so these
are all modifiers are going to help
somebody
get the click get them to click on your
link
and go to your website so when you don't
hit the 65 character lemonade if you go
over that
google's going to cut off the title text
so we want to
avoid that at all possible so the whole
idea is
you know like 10 best cooking dried fake
recipes by emily
that's a good enticing title tag okay
takes into account a modifier
includes the targeted keyword and is
under the 65 character count
some additional tips for writing meta
description
we always want to provide a unique
description for each web page of the
website
so no duplicate meta tag descriptions
every page use needs to be unique then
we also want to be specific
about what we're offering so if you have
say you're selling headphones and you
have a particular
set of headphones from a different
specific brand include that
in the meta description if you have that
particular product from that brand on
sale
include that in the meta description so
you want to be as specific as possible
the whole idea behind a meta description
is to describe the page but also to get
the end user to click on your link so
here's an example
of using modifiers and describing a page
if we look at amazon again we can see
this example here
and if we look at it on google search
results
so if i type in amazon bluetooth
headsets ten dollars are on sale
here we can see a lot of amazon listings
in google search here you can see the
use of modifiers in the title tag
and also in the meta description here we
could see that
you know this particular headset
bluetooth headset is on sale
50 off so if something's on sale feel
free to include it
be descriptive about the page let people
know where they're going
and use those modifiers don't be afraid
to use numbers
in the meta description even if it's the
price itself even if it's not on sale
but it is the price
included it's not going to hurt the more
information you can include in a meta
description
the better chance you have of somebody
clicking on that link
use numbers symbols you know percentages
off
always help use catchy words like
discount or cashback
you're competing with other listings on
the page so
if you have something on sale if it's on
clearance list that it's on clearance
here i can see they even included the
coupon code
so feel free to list as much specific
information about that page as possible
the whole idea is you're competing with
your own web pages but in other cases
with competitors
so the meta description along with the
title tag and the url
helps separate out you from the rest of
the listings on search engine results
and we don't want to keyword stuff we
want to keep it within 160
something characters or 160 65
characters
because google will break off the meta
description just like they do with the
title tag
and so we want clean natural written
meta descriptions
that separate you from the competition
so that means including the keywords but
making sure those keywords are naturally
included in the meta description so if i
go back again
to valleyfig.com and i could see the
meta description hey welcome to the best
resource online for dried fake recipes
savory is sweet snacks are healthy dried
food recipes
we've got it all start cooking with figs
and so it's natural sounding
it does include the keyword it's not
keyword stuffing it's natural sounding
that's hopefully
going to get that person to click on
this particular website
let's turn our attention to the url
so we want to make sure that the url
is basically taken into account best
practices so if we take a look at this
particular url here
it doesn't necessarily look as
attractive as we would like
so first of all i don't understand some
of it
so that makes it unpleasant boring and
messy to say the least
so you want urls that you know basically
are clean and understandable
so in other words we want to make them
seo friendly because if they're seo
friendly somebody understands the url
then they're likely going to click on it
so the old rule of thumb
is if you can read the url then the
search engines can read the url
so here are some tips for creating
friendly urls for seo make it readable
you want to include the target keyword
in the url so if it's dried figs
the url should include dried figs if
it's dried fig recipes
make sure it's dried fig recipes now
avoid using too many subdirectories in
the urls
so we want to keep it as close as
possible to the root directory
and match the urls to titles most of the
time so let's go back to our example
here
here we can see this is valleyfig.com
recipes not necessarily dried fig
recipes but recipes nonetheless
it's in the root directory okay so at
all cost
now this is in some cases unavoidable
given that
you may be dealing with an e-commerce
website
that's calling you know content from a
database
so if that is the case you're going to
have some dynamic parameters
in the url which is fine just make sure
you avoid having too many of those
dynamic parameters it's understandable
that parameters but the role of dom
generally is no more than two different
parameters
in the url so prefer to create short
urls that's really the way to go the
shorter
the better is the rule of thumb and you
know if you're going to
break up the url then use hyphens
instead of underscores it's just cleaner
it's a more understandable
search engines tend to read it a little
bit easier
if it's hyphen so here's what a friendly
url looks like for search you got your
domain you got a subcategory broken up
with a hyphen
and then the product so that's just a
clean url for a particular ecommerce
site that has categories and
subcategories
so again we got amazon.com your category
can be electronics your subcategory
could be earphones and your product
could be
boat earphones it's that simple let's
start with
talking about rich snippets this is tip
number four so we want to add
rich snippets to improve your website's
visibility on
serps so tip number four is all about
rich snippets so
let's start out by asking ourselves what
is a rich snippet so rich snippet is
simply just a term used
to describe structured data markup
that you as a website owner can add to
your html so hypertext markup language
or html
is what is basically constructs a page
if we can add
more information to that that will
in turn allow search engines like google
to better understand
the information that's on that web page
so the more google understands about
that web page the more they can
put into the search engine results page
so rich snippets
is basically some structured data markup
that
we can add to our existing html and so
if we want to add rich snippets to
search engines
then how would you prefer your products
to be displayed well
if we have products then we want to make
sure that maybe we have reviews or
maybe we have so um other information in
there
like links to our site okay so there's a
lot of different types of rich snippets
that
you know we can add that google can
recognize and add to the search engine
results
so if you have a product then there's a
lot of things we can add
like specifically product reviews so we
want to be able to add more
information to the search engine results
by
working in some rich snippets so
basically the whole idea is to set up
the rich snippet
to drive targeted traffic okay so
because the more information in the serp
the more likelihood you're going to get
the click and the more
likelihood that click is specific
traffic
so some of the benefits of structuring
the data for rich snippets are
as i mentioned increasing click-through
rates you know also increasing
conversion rates so when you get the
traffic
from organic search to your website if
somebody's looking for specific product
and you have
a number of different good reviews
showing up let's just say
five stars out of five stars and you
have 100 reviews showing 5 stars
then you know somebody's probably going
to send take some trust in your brand
and your conversion rate probability is
going to go higher
it also helps improve your search engine
visibility because you're adding more
information
so in other words the more google knows
about your page
the likelihood it's going to rank that
page and it's more
likely that that information that's
contained in that rich snippet is gonna
get featured
in either the knowledge graph which is
that graph on the right side
or in a featured snippet which usually
shows up at the top of search engine
results
so in other words the more information
you give google the more they can use
that information
on their search results page and there's
no disagreeing that the more information
that you have in your search engine
result
the likelihood of getting more traffic
increases
so for rich snippets you could always
start with
images so some of the common properties
that you can add
to your product page if you have a
product pages the page itself is an
image
you can always start there you can
always add a description
you can always add in ratings and you
can always add in reviews
so these are some of the most common
attributes you can add as a rich snippet
so if you add that google picks it up
it's going to include that information
in the search results okay some others
are offers
prices site links links to your site
and product availability so all that
information can be conveyed to google
google understands what you're trying to
pass along it's going to include that in
the search results
so did you know that according to ahrefs
over 99.58 of featured pages
that have structured data already rank
in the top 10 list of the google search
results page
so in other words if you have rich
snippets in your page
your chances of ranking in the top 10 of
a google result
is going to be very very very good okay
let's talk about tip number five
optimize your site structure for a great
user experience
so let's go over some of the tips that
you would do
for planning a good website for seo
and so tip number one is you want a url
structure that follows your
site's navigation hierarchy so obviously
home page
interior pages so depending on what type
of site you have
obviously the navigation needs to follow
that
site's navigation that's site hierarchy
and it all starts with the home page you
want to optimize your home homepage to
drive
traffic to your product pages so the
home page is nothing more than a doorway
into your website and so the site's
navigation
should link to all those different
products so if you have an e-commerce
site with
sub categories or categories
subcategories
then you want to be able to make sure
your navigation reflects that
you want to build a comprehensive
structure for internal linking as well
because when you're from the home page
obviously you want to be able
to easily navigate to other pages
however when you're on
other pages you want to be able to have
a link pointing back to
relevant pages and not necessarily on
the home page
so this serves two purposes one for the
end user
obviously you want the end user to
navigate through your website seamlessly
right
second for the search engines they're
following links they want to be able to
understand how your website flows and
links together
so you don't want a scenario where it's
a one-way
street from the home page to interior
pages you want basically a home page to
interior
interior to other relevant interior
pages
and that could be a lateral or that
could be a
situation where it's a hierarchy for
example home page
category subcategories sub sub category
etc
you want to be able to make sure your
site is constructed in a manner in which
the search engine can read it
so css or cascading style sheets
or hypertext markup language html
are your two most common languages
that's basically what browsers load
that's what search engines like to index
it just makes it easy
for them to understand what your page is
all about remember we talked about rich
snippets
in the previous tip rich snippets are
nothing more
than supplemental html to describe what
the page is all about
so that the search engines can
understand that page
and include reviews or include site
links
in the search engine results so this is
all based on html so the more you
provide the search engines in a more
structured manner
via html the more the search engines are
going to stay in the page
adding breadcrumbs to your product pages
is also a good practice
if you have an e-commerce site and you
have a category then a sub-category then
a sub-sub-category then a product page
well it's probably not a bad idea to
make sure you have a breadcrumb so that
was
that way somebody can easily go right
back from the product page
to say the category page or to the
subcategory page directly without having
to
hit the back button or having to go
through the navigation some good
examples
i think amazon is a good example of
using breadcrumbs
giving the amount of products they have
on their site so go check out amazon if
you want a good example
for breadcrumbs and then canonical tags
we want to make
good use of canonical tags and that's in
order to avoid duplicate content
so a canonical tag is nothing more than
a link element basically or an html
element that basically prevents
duplicate content issues so in other
words if we have a canonical tag as a
meta tag
basically we're telling the search
engines this is the preferred or
canonical version of a web page
so use this web page so it signals to
the search engines
which page they should basically index
and pay attention to
and avoid at all the other pages that
have similar
content so that's the idea behind a
canonical tag so that's a good best
practice
and then optimize your site for desktop
and mobile i can't stress the mobile
part enough
most users begin their journey on mobile
so if you're not sure about what the
search engines like or don't like
you can always refer to google search
console for an example
so if you go to google search console
they have a report
called mobile usability so if you click
on mobile usability you can see
what pages they like what pages they
don't like from a mobile perspective
and if you have errors they're going to
tell you what those errors are so if
your website has
text that's too small to read they're
going to tell you
that these are the pages with this error
and so that allows you to go and address
those errors because
from a google perspective if you have if
a page has
a mobile usability error then google
will not
index that page so leverage google
search console
to get a sense of what type of errors
your site has from a mobile perspective
you also want to prefer to keep your
checkout page simple so again from an
e-commerce
perspective you want to keep the
checkout page as simple as possible for
obvious reasons you want the end user
to have a good experience and you
obviously want the conversion
so when i say keep a checkout page
simple really now with today's
technology you can create
a one-page checkout process you want to
optimize your sitemap
so when we talk about sitemaps we want
to make sure
that it's a file and xml file that
basically
includes all of our urls
and we can then turn around and give
that site map to the search engines
so if you have a sitemap in xml make
sure you go to google search console so
if i go to google search console and i
click on site maps
i can just simply just tell google where
my site map is located
and when they recognize that sitemap
they're going to be able to
basically index the urls from that
sitemap so we can see here
how many urls they discover and how many
they index
so make sure you create the sitemap in
an xml format
submit the sitemap via google search
console and then you can go back and see
how many pages they've indexed versus
how many you've submitted
and you want to make sure that sitemap
is dynamic meaning
anytime you publish a url that url is
added to the sitemap
fixing broken links so broken links is
not
something you want but it's something
every website has
it's unavoidable you know people publish
pages all the time
there's test pages there's all sorts of
reasons why
a site has broken links you want to be
able to address those and again
going back to google search console we
can basically
see just by looking at some reports what
pages
have broken links and which ones don't
so we could certainly look at
search console to get information about
basically
what pages are broken which ones aren't
and then we want to
prefer predictive searches and integrate
product typographic errors on your
search bar
so basically have a search bar that's a
best practice
but anticipate knowing what people are
typing in
so that means maybe going into google
analytics and looking at the search
terms report so we can go into analytics
and look at search terms
to get a sense of what people are
searching for but you know when we talk
about
integrating product typographic errors
we're talking also about fonts so we
want to make sure we're using the latest
fonts
so that we don't run in any issues on
our website
uh people not being able to read based
on a specific font that you're using
and then as a best practice what i found
and this
is not necessarily for everyone but
using a live chat widget
sometimes helps in fact i would even go
beyond sometimes
most the time again depending on your
business but i see most businesses now
have live chat enabled
and so basically having live chat
enables somebody
who has a question to immediately reach
out to somebody versus picking up the
phone
versus sending an email it's just
instantaneous
gratification in some ways so inserting
live chat on a website
is more common practice than not
nowadays given
it it lends to a better user experience
thank you for attending today's session
if you have any more information
please visit simplylearn.com thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here